sie bekommt die Angst der Belarussen vor
den Entwicklungen im Land direkt zu
spüren Daria Schulz sowas Eltern wohnen
noch dort regelmäßig komme der
Geheimdienst bei Ihnen vorbei
meine Eltern bekommen oft Besuch von
denen und sie werden jedes Mal gefragt
wo ich bin ich denke dann immer das
nächste mal fragen Sie nicht nur nach
meinem Aufenthalt
Daria ist Journalistin für den
belarussischen Exil Sender belsad in
Warschau ihre Eltern sind deswegen in
Gefahr sie hat Angst dass sie irgendwann
festgenommen werden und dass sie sie
nicht wieder sieht
Rückblick 2020 berichtete Daria aus
Minsk über die Proteste gegen
Lukaschenko monatelang gingen
Zehntausende auf die Straße sie warfen
dem machte aber Wahlmanipulation vor der
ließ die Demonstrationen brutal
niederschlagen hunderte wurden
festgenommen unter ihnen war auch Daria
der Vorwurf an Stiftung zum Aufstand die
Haftbedingungen Menschen unwürdig
teilweise pflichte man sie mit 11
Personen in eine Zelle
[Musik]
dort waren geschlossen
es stand die ganze Zeit direkt aus der
Kanalisation
wir saßen dort und warteten nur darauf
zu ersticken
zwei Jahre saß Daria im Gefängnis bis
sie frei kam und ihr Heimatland
verlassen konnte
in Belarus schien es jahrelang so als
wäre Lukaschenko nur noch ein Machthaber
von Putins Gnaden der russische
Präsident hatte ihn während der Proteste
gestützt
doch nach dem Wagner Aufstand
präsentiert sich Lukaschenko
selbstbewusst seine Botschaft nur er
habe erfolgreich zwischen Putin und
pregorjin vermitteln können
er teilt sogar mit dass seine
Streitkräfte Moskau notfalls zur Hilfe
geeilt werden
alle Streitkräfte einschließlich der
Polizei und der Spezialkräfte wurden in
volle Kampfbereitschaft versetzt die
gesamte Brigade war bereits nach
Russland verlegt zu werden
das kleine Belarus präsentiert sich als
Retter des mächtigen Krümel einer Frau
für Putin und dann verkündet Lukaschenko
auch noch stolz die Zusammenarbeit mit
dem Verräter Priorin
wenn die Wagner Kommandeure zu uns
kommen und uns helfen ist das eine gute
Erfahrung sie kämpfen an vorderster
Front das sind Sturmtruppen sie werden
uns sagen was im Moment wichtig ist
die Stimmung in Minsk heute ruhig noch
ist nicht bekannt ob außer Jewgeni
pregorian weitere wagnertruppen im Land
sind doch eines ist klar Alexander
Lukaschenko fühlt sich als Gewinner des
gescheiterten wagneraufstandes
ein Albtraum für die Opposition das
erzählt sie uns Swetlana tiranowskaja
sie war 2020 die Gegenkandidatin
Lukaschenkos auch sie musste fliehen und
beobachtet jetzt aus dem Exil mit
Schrecken das Wagner Kämpfer nach
Belarus kommen könnten
wirklich frauenhaft dann eine russische
Söldnertruppe könnte Belarus
kontrollieren das kann unsere Bürger in
Schwierigkeiten bringen ich bekomme die
Reaktion der Menschen mit einerseits
haben sie natürlich Angst andererseits
sind sie aber auch sehr wütend über die
Situation
die Situation in Belarus ist schlimm
findet auch Daria Schulz sova sie macht
sich große Sorgen um ihre Familie und
ihre Freunde die noch im Land sind
[Musik]
heute weiß ich dass ich gerade nicht
nach Hause zurückgehen kann
ich würde sehr sehr gerne zurückkehren
aber ich kann nicht ich sitze und mit
diesem Gefühl muss ich jeden Tag leben
die Nachrichten vom Wochenende über
brigosin und Wagner machen Daria große
Angst um ihre Familie und die Zukunft
ihres Landes
[Musik]